foreign
[Music]
good afternoon
so
many of you probably have seen or tried
to help workplace without art
so this is a typical case I see
your company hired our trainer went over
a lot of fancy things possible in our
with the team after the training
everyone finds are very cool
teddy bears amazing all markdown awesome
shiny fantastic but then after a few
days most people just went back to the
go to tools I'd rather not call it out
but something that's not r
several years ago my company moved to R
and we faced the same situation to help
change that I initiated a work
automation project with r and now
we have 20 plus team members who
consider hard to go to tools 60 plus
stakeholders who use our product on a
daily basis and this has saved over 12
000 hours and counting
in the next 15 minutes I'm going to talk
about key parts of the project Lessons
Learned and the structure you could
follow if you would like to implement it
now let's revisit the situation
we want to move things to R but why are
there many movements
well
we all have learning curve as beginners
some of us went through it quicker more
of us don't
the other scenario I can think of is
that after the training we are not asked
to handle the right tasks some of those
tasks might not even be covered in the
training they may look similar though
even if you were able to avoid the first
two you may still end up in the last
situation where you have a grand plan of
what to do with with your project using
r but I had to go back to the old ways
because your deadline is the same
now
unfortunately before realizing any of
these we're assumed everything will work
after the training when it didn't we
just thought we need to work harder on
the next one
in fact in one of those follow-up
training I provided I even remade The
Lion King song into can you use the r
tonight summarizing the r functions we
talked about but it's still did not help
turns out what we need is to create a
soft Landing that will start small and
help the team to build confidence
identify the task for them and plan the
effort for the transition
my soft Landing idea then was to build a
work automation project using R and next
I'm going to talk about the six key
parts of the project and in the end you
will see why that was perfect for this
situation
so to build an automation project first
let's look into was possible
at that time I was a member of a data
team and for most data teams on this
planet you cannot escape from reports
so let's take a look at a typical report
if we can describe it step by step like
traveling on a map
you first
open your app maybe it's a SQL database
data Lake all that
then you update your parameter and run
then you wait
export the data clean the results
analyze it update the format draft an
email and send
but then if you look again it almost
looks like all of these steps can be
divided into three portions where we
just use different groups of application
for some of those reports I would start
with Oracle move on to Excel and then
end it with Outlook for other reports I
would just use other applications
but regardless of the difference of
those applications we all seem to start
from getting the data then do the data
wrangling analysis visualization and end
it with communication
so if you have a report that have any
parts that fix any of those three
portions we can replace that portion
with our code with the help of those R
packages
and the good thing is there are so many
of these R packages
now
Sans for the reports that will take some
efforts but how about this the processes
whose pain point was running the tax
itself and sharing the result on a daily
basis
how about the stakeholder request we
will just require you to run a SQL query
and share the data
well they still fit in the scope of this
automation project we just need a little
bit more help
when defining automation
there are three types
so the first type or the one perfect for
the reports that will still need some
human involvement
and that would be perfect to be done
with our code
the second type are the ones that good
for the process that does not
necessarily need human input but will
need to happen at a certain time
and will be best with r plus our studio
connect
lastly also my favorite a combination of
the previous two
in this in this case
the human input will come from
stakeholder and they can kick off
whatever processes that will get them
the answer with the help of shiny
now if we look at these
definitions
none of those are new but the current R
ecosystem was able to offer a brand new
interpretation
so after knowing what can be done in the
project and what the current R ecosystem
can help you with time to sell it to
decision makers
and whenever you're selling something
you want to talk about its benefits so
what are the benefits here
reproducibility the first word popping
my head then we may get a last human
error if we code everything correctly
and if we were able to achieve the first
two we were able to be able to save some
time
so
I gotta do a few decision makers in the
room presented them my plan of
automating all the tasks identified in
Step One along with the benefits here if
I could replicate the third interest
level using a gauge here
so when I first talk about
reproducibility I gave them an example
if I'm out of office someone else can
run all the tasks that I'm handling
their interest level wasn't very high
maybe because it sounded very similar to
a travel insurance where it is not
urgent at the moment you would only miss
it after things happen
then I moved on with Alaska mirror but
not additional interest because maybe
they were thinking it is all theoretical
and code is written by human too
lastly our saved
more interest and then they even ask me
if I have any numbers but overall I did
not get the go-ahead this is when I
realized I was so ready and so prepared
to sell this whole thing to our user
who is more concerned about the
day-to-day workflow but not decision
makers who have no programming
experience and who is more concerned
about the return or investment as well
as business insurgencies
so I waited a few weeks just after
everybody forgot about what I said and
updated my strategy and this is what I
presented
so I started with
R was saved in fact I told them if we go
through with this we might be able to
save 1000 hours per year
they're interested
then I moved on to last human error
uh if we code everything correctly
they're still intrigued lastly I sold
reproducibility like a free add-on
travel insurance who would love that
overall we got to go ahead but then if
you look back it is still the same
number of benefits just in a slightly
different order I guess sometimes it
makes sense for us to start with the one
that does not require too much context
to understand and now you see why I
named The Talk saving 1000 hours with
rstudio not bringing reproducibility
with rstudio uh if that was dark name I
don't know if half of you will show up
or even I would show up
so after get the decision makers Buy in
time to get the things we need to do the
actual automation
high level there are two things a
document of the current process that we
know what needs to be done and the
information for us to compare to all the
tasks so that we know which one to start
with
to get the documentation we will need to
understand the current processes
well you may say wouldn't that just need
uh tools and steps mostly yes but we
will also need to understand the
business reasons so that we can
accommodate any changes that may end up
making the process better
we will also need to understand the
occurrence whether it happens daily
weekly or ad hoc so that we can choose
the best platform or tool for it
lastly we tend to forget a communication
as part of the Automation and I would
always recommend saving a few
communication examples in your document
on top of that we also want to know the
current efforts in terms of the overall
time for each run
before the automation
and what's the manual versus processing
time breakdown and identifying the tough
items through this process
ideally the automation should always
work
if we code things right but oftentimes
it is not ideal which is why it is
critical for us to know how often should
we update the process of document so
that we know when it will be obsolete
and oftentimes we're not always the
original report owner
so we need to know when to stop and call
for additional help
now all of these will get us a detailed
document of the requirements of course
it's always a great opportunity to
practice our markdown
but other than the document itself we
now know
the complexity of potentially automating
this process
the impact as well as the stability
which would allow you to rank all your
tasks in a table that looks like this
so if you're wondering which one to
start
you may not want to start with task
number one where it is complicated it
has small impact and may require you to
update the code every other week
you may want to consider starting from
automating task number three where it is
not overly complicated we'll earn you
some recognition and there's your last
need to for you to update the code and
then maybe you can move on to the harder
ones
after knowing what is needed identifying
the task to start with time to roll out
the sleeves
now to do the actual automation there
are so many things to cover here in fact
I've been working on an automation book
trying to cover all the common scenarios
using uh two dozens of chapters so I
would just be brief here with my top
three recommendations
my first recommendation is to always
start with components let's just say if
you have a process that separately
involves SQL Excel and outflow you want
to code them one by one because within
the same team an organization the same
processes will involve the similar
components where you can just reuse the
code
my second recommendation is that we
should definitely do plenty of tests to
capture all the scenarios possible while
there would be dependency tests user
test Dev test unit test we should do all
the applicable ones
I know everybody trusts their own code I
do too but the reality has taught me to
trust the task even more
lastly be practical and stay on target
I know it feels great to be able to
build all solutions within R but the
thing is not everything needs to be
fully automated at the end of the day it
is not about building something cool
with r
but building something impactful with r
I've got lost in that so many times so
let me say this again it is not about
building something cool with r but
building something impactful with our
now after the coding uh task is all done
we can now just hand off a process and
move on
but there are still things we need to
look out for in order to keep the
project going
overall there are three deadly
situations that could affect your
project
the first situation is that after you
hand it off your automated processes
someone ran the code but the result
isn't what's expected because maybe
because uh the script wasn't handled
properly like running it on a new
machine or a new environment without the
proper setup
believe it or not after all these years
it still happens to me
So to avoid this situation what I would
recommend is to always have a handout
document that discussed the requirements
of the job instructions of running the
process testing the process and what to
do to maintain
the second scenario is that as you build
more and more automated processes
chances are multiple processes may run
into issues at the same time
and sometimes someone will come up and
they need your help to fix it
sometimes multiple people will show up
which could look pressing
so my tip for you is this
always discuss the fail save in your
handoff document in most cases a line
like this would do the trick this is
almost like when the autopilot stop
working you don't stop flying or driving
you switch back to manual and this often
reduce the urgency and give us the time
to properly fix the issue
lastly everything went well you just got
a new feature request should you
directly jump in
and my recommendation here well two
recommendations the short term is that
always treat it like a brand new task so
that you can start from Gathering
requirements and that you can best
determine
when to work on it and that the longer
term solution here is that it is also a
perfect opportunity for you to train
your individual team members to
gradually take on the task and
accumulate more our knowledge
now after you're comfortable with
dealing with those three situations we
just need to give it time for the
project to make progress
and just like any of the other projects
from time to time you want to share
updates
and to do that
I often find it helpful to start with
the key stats for example our saved
which is something you can easily
extract from the requirement document
that you have built in the previous
steps
and the number of process documents now
available because of this project as
well as the all the training that
happened because throughout this project
whether it would be the official one
well the one-on-one sessions that you
had with your team members
on top of that you also want to share
any of the success stories learnings
that happen along the way and maybe you
give kudos to your team member that you
collaborated with and lastly you don't
want to forget talking about the hurdles
where you could use additional help on
other than that you also want to
determine a good Cadence to share
progress for me it was once a month but
you should always set up your own and
know that you can share progress
whenever you have critical updates
now that wraps out the key parts of the
project if you would like to start
something similar at your workplace
this is a structure you could follow
first start from identifying the task in
your workplace
then
build your proposal with the benefits
that would matter to your decision
makers and workplace
after that build a requirement document
would possibly with our markdown
identify the right task to start with
then
code by component do plenty of tests and
stay on target
while at the same time try to stay away
from the three deadly situations
and don't forget to share progress from
time to time
now I would like to ask everyone to
think back about the original situation
as we build more and more automated
processes we have completely moved on
from the original question of why the r
adoption rate isn't what's expected
after the r training to now having most
team members owning several of these R
processes where they were at least
involved in
building the requirements testing the
process and execution
rather than expecting everyone to
connect the our functionalities to the
business needs through the r training we
connect the business needs to the r
functionalities through this project and
we just happen to save thousands of
hours
now if you're a decision maker in this
room this might be a good project to
make some impact and accumulate some R
knowledge
if you're a team member in this room
bring this back and start from
identifying the tasks
if you're one of the two team members in
this room
tax your boss now and say you have an
idea
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]